on
passe maintenant à notre terriens du
samedi
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous les deux bonsoir fight
bonsoir du mien il ya deux ans jour pour
jour les frères kwasi pénétrer dans les
locaux de charlie hebdo la suite on la
connaît huit journalistes assassinés
plus de policiers plus jeune employé de
la sodexo +1 gens s inviter dounia
bouzar bonsoir vous êtes anthropologue
et vous avez fondé le centre de
prévention contre les dérives sectaires
liées à l'islam farid benyettou bonsoir
vous êtes celui que l'on surnommait les
meilleurs des buttes chaumont au début
des années 2000 vous étiez le mentor des
frères kwasi mais après attentats de
charlie hebdo devez contacter dounia
pour la rejoindre dans son combat contre
la radicalisation
aujourd'hui ou publier ensemble un livre
intitulé monde yade itinéraire d'un
repenti aux éditions autrement et vous
en parlait dans salut les terriens
je sais qu'il ya déjà un débat pour
savoir s'il fallait vous invité ou pas
fayyad moi je pense qu'il faut vous
invitez je pense qu'il faut vous écouter
et qu'il faut se faire une idée le
téléspectateur sont capables de se faire
leur idée on n'a pas nous animateur à
leur dire ce qu'ils doivent penser
farid est né le 10 mai 1981 à paris père
agent d'entretien mère femme au foyer
vous avez trois frères et une soeur
votre famille vit dans un f5 du 19e
arrondissement de paris près des buttes
chaumont
et quand votre père découvre qu'il a été
adopté il se tourne dans la religion
et là vous vous rendez dans une mosquée
pour prendre des cours d'arabe et pour
assister à des conférences religieuses
et vous partez en vacances grâce aux
frères musulmans c'est à dire que dès
l'âge de 11 ans votre conscience
politique se constitue en voyant le sort
des musulmans bosniaques en yougoslavie
et vous impliquer de plus en plus dans
l'humanitaire donc ce qu'on peut dire
c'est qu'au début ça n'est que naturel
tout ça c'est exactement ça c'est depuis
le début j'ai baigné un petit peu de
temps dans un environnement même temps
lié à la religion pratique de la
religion et en même temps les moniteurs
avec le secours islamique la cause
bosniaque était très présente c'est là
où je découvre un petit peu le conflit
tout ce qui se passe là bas j'ai
l'impression que personne ne fait rien
et ça ça me révolte
en 1994 après le décès de sa mère
adoptive
votre père sombre dans l'alcoolisme et
là vous n'avez plus de figure paternelle
et votre père devient même un modèle a
fui hier quand je perds mon père je
perds tous mes repères en fait et je
cherche quelque chose et ces pères de
substitution vous les trouverez chez les
frères musulmans dans un premier temps
chez les frères musulmans avec le sco
islamique avec une certaine pratique de
la religion ça me plaise mais je
m'épanouis mais j'ai besoin de quelque
chose de plus à 15 ans vous découvrez la
salafia
salafia donc c'est vivre vraiment comme
à l'époque du prophète en respectant mot
à mot les préceptes du prophète mohamed
vous portez le kalliste dans le cabinet
d'une longue chemise
dans le quartier vous suscitez le
respect à partir de là c'est à dire que
les gens vous vous vénèrent d'une
certaine façon parce que vous affirmez
votre foi en l'islam à partir du moment
où je tape cette tenue vestimentaire jeu
on attribue cette étiquette de quelqu'un
de pieux de religieux je suscite
l'admiration pour certains alors que
c'est une carapace est une coquille vide
bientôt vous porter le turban
et vous mettez à étudier les textes
sacrés de l'islam au lycée donc vous
devenez le un peu le prédicateur de la
cour de récréation et c'est un oxymore
absolument incroyable puisque vous êtes
au lycée voltaire vous appelle l'imam
voltaire c'est un gâchis mort assez
extraordinaire là vous conseiller aux
filles de porter le voile et ça marche
enfin vous sentez chez les jeunes
musulmans qui sont là un besoin
d'identitaires en fait je sens que les
gens sont attentifs à ce que je leur dit
et moi quelque part aussi ça va mal ça
me ça me conforte dans l'idée que j'ai
enfin trouvé un sens à ma vie ouais
niveau scolaire c'est plutôt le
décrochage et là je me dis c'est ça que
je vais faire je vais transmettre cette
religion en tout cas la main avant la
cage de la console via ce moment là je
vais faire ça pendant ma vie et là vous
devenez le parfait salafistes vous dites
je percevais toute activité comme
pouvant me détourner de dieu c'est à
dire je me sentais coupable
rien de penser à un loisir dire que
quand vous voyez quelqu'un qui fait une
photo dans la rue vous détournez ça
quand vous voyez quelqu'un qui joue de
la musique dans le métro vous trouvez ça
satanique c'est une angoisse permanente
en fait c'est l'angoissé permanente de
de trahir sa religion quand je vois
quelqu'un dont la fois dans la rue qui
prend la main qui prend des photos des
touristes par exemple je change
carrément de trottoir j'ai pas envie
d'être d'être pris dans le cadre parce
que j'ai l'impression que nous le
faisons ça je suis complice et
c'est insoutenable 5e bientôt farid vous
passez du salafisme djihadisme jusque là
vous demandiez à la religion de sauver
votre âme et là vous demandez à la
religion de sauver le monde c'est une
autre chanson ça répond à vos besoins
que j'avais à ce moment là j'avais
l'impression de ne pas avoir mon rôle
je me projetais pas dans l'avenir
scolairement j'avais complètement
décrochés hélas non seulement on parle
de ces injustices qui m'avait déjà
touché des pilotes au et en plus on
propose des tracteurs ouais et tout ça
avec la religion arrêtée à briquet
ensemble c'est exact de penser à ce
moment là que vous avez trouvé votre
voix c'est ça ma vie un sens des
criminels deviennent un peu vos modèles
je suis complètement dans le déni de
tout ce qui se passe la réalité je veux
pas la voir et c'est le discours que je
vais avoir tu me tenir jusqu'au bout le
11 septembre 2001 vous ne voyez que
l'aspect symbolique de l'attentât vous
n'avez aucun état d'âme pour les
victimes ben laden à l'époque c'est
votre héros quand je découvre les
attentats du 11 septembre je vois pas du
tout les personnes les êtres humains
n'existent pas l'idéologie djihadiste
nous amène comme ça petit à petit au
début avec une belle utopie on va sauver
le monde de fil en aiguille on arrive
tout ça c'est à ce stade là celui de la
déshumanisation voit plus les gens comme
des êtres humains mais comme des
catégories c'est d'aimer créances et des
ennemis c'est des traîtres c'est ceci
c'est cela ne va pas l'être humain qui
est derrière et c'est comme ça moi qu'il
n'y a plus aucune empathie pour l'être
humain absolument aucune l'année
suivante vous devenez abou abdallah et
tous les jours donner des cours dans un
coin de la mosquée à l'abri des regards
et bientôt un nouveau groupe de jeunes
vient vers vous et parmi eux parmi ces
jeunes il ya les frères coinche
chérif kouachi
lui va être former au djihad parce qu'il
veut rejoindre l'irak que les américains
s'apprêtent en d'ailleurs comment s'est
passée votre première rencontre avec
chérif kouachi bon déjà d'emblée je
connaissais son projet de se rendre en
irak et on m'avait demandé de le
soutenir et c'est ce que j'ai fait c'est
ce que j'ai fait je les soutenais dans
ce projet je les encourage et j'essaie
de le renforcer de lui dire qu'il était
sur la bonne voie que sa démarche était
tout à fait nabeul et
c'est pour ça que j'ai été condamné par
la suite chérif kouachi a prévu de
partir en irak un matin de janvier 2005
ce jour-là un 6 heures du matin les
flics débarquent chez vous
vous êtes arrêté
après deux jours de garde à vue vous
avouer oui je suis bien celui qu'on
appelle les meilleurs des buttes
chaumont en prison vous reprenez votre
rôle de prédicateur
vous faites des appels à la prière
depuis la fenêtre et vous conduisez les
célébrations de l'aid ce prosélytisme
décide l'administration de vous
transférée à fresnes
trois ans plus tard farid arrive votre
procès vous êtes condamné à six ans de
prison vous ne ferez que 4 avait été
arrêté sous perben libéré dessous
rachida dati il passe ou taubira comme
quoi
alors 1 sorti de prison on peut penser
que j'allais retrouver vos parents votre
famille extérieur mais avant d'aller
voir votre famille avant d'aller voir
vos parents vous allez voir dj à 10 vous
dites je me suis empressé de retrouver
les djihadistes avant la famille farid
c'était ma famille
léger a dit c'était la famille que
j'avais choisi c'était avec eux que je
me sentais en sécurité c'est avec lui
que je me sentais bien c'était mes
repères j'avais besoin de les voir
c'était
comme une addiction je m'étais promis
depuis les voir de tourner la page le
premier réflexe ça a été les voir eux en
premier enfin désormais vous avez quand
même des doutes vous devenez élèves
infirmiers
v une bourse
la france vous donne une bourse pour
vous résumer
en mars 2012 la france découvre les
assassinats de mohamed merah vous
chantez coupable quand vous apprenez ça
vous est paniquée vous mangez plus vous
dormez plus
vous dites quand même derrière les idées
que je professe il ya des morts mohamed
merah ça va être vous aime pas le mot
mais ça va être vraiment le déclic ouais
mohamed merah un peu comme tout le monde
j'ai vu d'abord les morts et des morts à
qui je vais m'identifier très rapidement
des gens d'origine maghrébine je vois
même pas l'uniforme c'est des militaires
mais ça je le vois même pas je vois
d'abord les êtres humains ce qui leur
est arrivé ça aurait pu m'arriver rebond
en fin de compte je me dis que celui qui
a fait ça c'est quelqu'un c'est un
raciste et voilà ils auraient pu s'en
prendre à moi comme comme à eux c'est la
même chose et le jour où j'ai découvre
qui a fait ça et qu'il a fait ou non
cette idéologie que j'ai défendus que
j'ai soutenu pendant toutes ces années
voilà je suis pro bien je suis pris au
piège parce qu'avant j'avais ce réflexe
mois toujours d'aller de mettre les gens
dans des catégories la soirée était très
facile c'était des militaires mais les
avait déjà vus comme des êtres humains
j'étais pris au piège là tout s'est
effondré voilà alors là vous continuer
vos études d'infirmier et vous
progressez vous accepté de mettre des
patchs sur le torse de femme nue vous
acceptez de vous raser la barbe parce
que vous on vous dit bon ça fait mauvais
genre à l'hôpital en fait à partir de
l'un farid vous n'avez plus peur de
l'enfer c'est ça j'ai plus cette
angoisse cette angoisse permanente
dans laquelle j'ai baigné pendant toutes
ces années le seul avec qui vous garder
contact c'est chérif kouachi alors ce
qu'on sait pas c'est veut-il vous
ramener dans le droit chemin est-ce
qu'il est envoyé pour sa part les
djihadistes ou au contraire me till vous
parler de ces tendances pédophiles parce
que la police a découvert sur
l'ordinateur de kouassi qu'il avait des
tendances pédophiles il avait un
problème avec ça a attiré par les
enfants moi par la suite j'ai beaucoup
doute parce que je sais que quand on
allait visiter une personne n'avait sa
fille qui était présente qu avait à peu
près 7 8 ans et demandé qu'elle soit pas
plus présente parce que a commencé à
être une femme
vous voyez chef kwasi pour la dernière
fois en novembre 2014 il a doublé de
volume il est bourré de protéines il est
gonflé par la muscu et omnibulé par un
pare neige le 7 janvier 2015 vous
découvrez que chérif et said kwasi sont
les auteurs du massacre de charlie hebdo
et ils ont du style venger le prophète
alors vous avez su lui transmettre le
jihad en 2004 mais vous n'avez pas su
lui enlever l'idée du jihad dix ans plus
tard en fait c'est ça qui m'angoisse
vous êtes co responsable bien sûr
j'ai prêché l'idéologie de la haine
pendant des années c'est pas c'est une
belle utopie comme à présenter au départ
c'est une idéologie qui appelle à tuer
des gens et moi j'ai prêché à ça pendant
des années c'est ça la réalité et ma ma
part de responsabilité elle est là j'ai
du mal à dire mais elle est là elle est
là elle est là il faut le dire alors là
vous êtes obligé d'interrompre votre
stage à la pitié salpêtrière
mais vous prenez conscience
que malgré votre passé la france vous a
donné une bourse pour faire des études
et que ces études vous ont permis de
devenir infirmier on ne m'a jamais
discret il est en ne m'a jamais
discriminés en france malgré m'en passer
oui la france tient ses promesses
contrairement aux djihadistes la france
tient ses promesses la vous décidez
farid contact et dounia bouzar qui
décide de vous intégrer dans son
programme de déradicalisation quand vous
l'avez vu arriver dounia vous avez pensé
quoi je n'ai vu arriver par téléphone
pendant plus de six mois ouais j'ai fait
comme d'habitude j'étais très méfiante
parce que c'est très difficile de savoir
si quelqu'un fait le deuil de l'utopie
ou pas aux faits sont blancs
donc on s'est beaucoup parlé
et je cherchais à voir si il était
honnête et s'il était capable de faire
ce que j'appelle une rétro analyse 1
pourquoi j'y croyais s'il assumer ses
responsabilités s'il avait expliqué
pourquoi sa durée des nus et des nus et
des nuits évidemment dans ces cas là
soit on a confiance soit on pense qu'il
fait de la kaka kaka c'est la
dissimulation dire que farid aujourd'hui
qui nous parle en fait il nous parle
pousserez 10 mai mais au fond dans sa
tête il a toujours l'idée du djihad il
va le refaire ses seins attaque là je
lui ai fait confiance à partir de mon
nom il m'a donné des secrets du
djihadisme là vous avez la conviction
qu'en fait il n'était pas dans la takia
quand il m'a donné des secrets oui alors
patrick peloux lundi dans le figaro
farid c'est comme si on demandait une
marque de cigarettes de se charger de
campagne anti tabac se comprend patrick
collot je comprends qu'on soit dans
l'émotion mais moi mon travail c'est
d'avancer c'est de travailler pour
lutter contre cette idéologie et je peux
pas me passer de doughty
parce que même si je continue à pleurer
on doit être fort on doit se battre et
on doit mieux de comprendre les fils
invisibles pour les combattre parce que
c'est pas qu'une guerre d'âge il
détruisent aussi nos repères émotionnel
nous repèrent civilisationnel il faut
rentrer dans leur univers qui a vu les
djihadistes leur vrai visage qui les a
vus dans les yeux pour bien nous montrer
les fils invisibles
ce sont les repentis il vous a aidé à
sauver des gens du djihad à lui tout
seul le peu de temps où il a été
bénévole il a sauvé une trentaine de
jeunes qui étaient des jeunes qui
étaient en train de faire leur ceinture
qui étaient des jeunes très impliqué
c'est pour ça que dès que j'ai arrêté
avec la mission ministérielle et que
j'ai refusé la reconduction puisque j'ai
été missionné un an par le ministère de
l'intérieur immédiatement je lui ai
demandé de s'impliquer avec nous
pourrons sauver d'autres parce que j'ai
vu qu'il était efficace et qui savaient
leur mettre le doute vous enlever
quelqu'un de l'idéologie jihadiste pour
vous montrer le vrai visage des
djihadistes travaillent avec vous
pourquoi il travaille pas avec la dgsi
il serait aux états unis la cei alors
est embauchée depuis longtemps ce mail
oui mais même au maroc même en italie
pourquoi faut-il toujours qu'en france
on soit en retard pourquoi va-t-il
falloir qu'on met en place ces
programmes que dans cinq ans parce qu on
y viendra alors qu'est ce que c'est une
bonne idée de sortir ce livre moment de
l'anniversaire des attentats de charlie
hebdo dounia on s'est dit on va redonner
de l'espoir aux gens on va leur dire que
on peut on peut se défendre on veut plus
on a 300 morts tous sur la conscience
ensemble et on ne veut plus de ça et là
finalement ça tombe au moment de cet
anniversaire mais on veut dire aux gens
c'est possible d'en sortir et on se
donnant tous la main policiers et tous
on s'en sortira farid dernière question
est ce que vous êtes charlie
[Musique]
de sorte que les sharks
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu